I'm unwilling to deny the existence of
free choice merely because I don't
understand it because it looks to me
like that's how people act that's how
they expect to be treated and that
societies who that could structure
themselves in accordance with the idea
that people have free choice actually
work
now that doesn't prove that there's free
choice but people have been arguing
about that forever so but it looks to me
so those are two possible means of
integration and then I think what you're
doing is feeding one or the other
constantly and I think you probably
choose which one to feed I think that's
and I mean that's how it feels that way
to me as well like when I look at my own
you know
maybe you're really aggravated with
something maybe you're aggravated with
your wife you know or your child or
something like that you know and you're
feeling kind of nasty and maybe even
know that you're in the wrong and an
idea comes into your head you think I
could say that and you know you could
say it and you know what it would do but
then you pause and you think would that
make it better or worse and then maybe
you go to hell with it which is a quite
the thing to say I've got a little story
about that in a minute and then you say
it but you knew you knew that you took
the low road right and you know it and
then you're guilty about that and
defensive and that makes the fight way
worse because then there's no damn way
you're gonna admit that you actually did
that and so things do go to hell and so
so here's here's an ugly little idea so
that's that's that's relevant to the
question so imagine you're playing
around with cocaine now I'm using
cocaine because it's very addictive but
it's a very interesting chemical because
it's a dopaminergic agonist and what
what dopamine does is two things it
makes you feel like what you're doing is
worthwhile but it also imagine that
there's a bunch of neural circuits that
are active and then they get a hit of
dopamine or you do then those neural
circuits get a little bit more powerful
okay so it it has a rewarding property
which is that it makes you feel like
what
doing is important and it has a
reinforcing property which is it makes
neural circuits grow so now what that
means is that whatever you were doing
just before you took cocaine grows okay
so now imagine there's a bunch of
different things that you do just before
you take cocaine but there's a string of
decisions and at one decision point is
the same for all of those difference
occurrences and that decision point is
because you know you're in trouble and
that decision point is well to hell with
it okay so then you think that each of
the two hundred times that you take
cocaine even though you do it in
different places but that one thought is
there all the time and that thing grows
because you're reinforcing it and it
grows and it grows and it grows and so
now that's in you that's that's part of
you and it's the thing that says to hell
with it okay so now and maybe that's not
such a good thing to grow inside your
brain so then you you're addicted and
they take you to a cocaine treatment
center and after a week you're no longer
physically physiologically addicted
you're not craving you don't have a
problem as long as you're there but then
they take you back to your normal
environment and you see like cocaine Joe
your friend and as soon as you see him
up that thing comes and bang you're back
on the you're back on the to hell with
the track and that's well you're in well
you're where you will end up too if you
reinforce that particular perspective
long enough so that's akin in a sense to
the this decision-making process you
know if you if you take the low road
then that wins and it gets a little
stronger because everything that wins
neurologically gets a little stronger
it's like a Darwinian competition so one
rule is don't practice what you don't
want to become because you really do
become that it builds it builds itself
right into your neural architecture and
that's one of the terrifying things
about addiction you know because you
think well it's kind of psychological
it's like yeah kind of it's also kind of
neuro physiological and you build a
one-eyed cocaine monster in your
and if you hit yourself enough with
something that reinforcing so yeah